E aí galera que assiste meu canal tudo
bom com vocês hoje o vídeo é diferente e
especial queria muito que você prestar
essa atenção porque hoje é o dia
nacional da língua brasileira de sinais
Olha aí a gente tem uma empresa de
tecnologia chamada Tron lá no Piauí que
mexe com educação e parar de tecnologia
desde criança e a gente tava
desenvolvendo uma parada para pessoas
com deficiência auditiva poder sentir a
música A Gente trouxe aqui para o teatro
para fazer os primeiros testes e a
reação Foi muito massa eu queria que se
você gostasse apoiasse o projeto Não
deixasse seguir a tronco e de clicar no
gostei aqui mas a gente ver também o
Comenta aí embaixo O que que você achou
e enfim fica com um vídeo aí porque eu
achei muito legal e fiquei muito feliz
de fazer hoje quando José
pede desculpa para ele aí para a gente
não saber falar deles
uma experiência mais emocionante de
sentir a música e dançar não só porque
tá observando os colegas mas sentiu o
mesmo que eles estão sentindo também o
mais próximo possível essa música é
minha para
as pessoas sentirem no tom da música
[Música]
tá legal
porque a gente consegue sentir essa
diferença da música da batida
eu acho que nessa região é um pouco
melhor época que distribui por todos os
óxidos também foi muito bom mas se for
aqui aqui
eu tenho acabado é um pouco diferente a
gente consegue sentir tudo mas tem a
diferença entre mas aqui nessa região
nessa forma de música o sentimento que a
gente estava no meu corpo eu nunca havia
sentido
é muito importante porque a gente possa
ter essas mesmas experiências porque
todos somos humanos de forma igual né
então surdo Ele dá ele consegue dançar
ele consegue sentir e agradecer a eles
que a participação dele foi muito
importante porque ele foi o 1º aí pronto
a gente procura de novo para você ver a
melhor versão do negócio bonitinho com
design bonito bem feito
tipo assim eu vou ensinar também porque
é muito importante essa comunicação com
certeza obrigado obrigado vocês
me conhecer você e eu fiquei muito feliz
porque é a primeira vez que a encontrar
alguém né pessoalmente que tem essa
visão pela acessibilidade
a proposta da empresa dele por exemplo é
introduzir a tecnologia
na vida da pessoa desde criança tá
ligado porque tipo assim às vezes os
pais da gente não não sabe
sentou no controle saiu da televisão o
cara fica sem assistir uma semana porque
ele tem um estranhamento da tecnologia
tá ligado ele é distante dela mas
recente tem na grade curricular desde
criança quando você saber tem direitinho
aí a empresa dele tem um kit que é todo
didático realmente para criança não é
para criança virar um engenheiro ele vai
catrônico não é para ele crescer dentro
do mundo da tecnologia porque tem gente
que não não paga por exemplo na
maquininha o negócio do shopping que
quer pagar com uma pessoa mesmo tá
ligado que quer pegar a fila mesmo mas é
porque tem essa distância tá ligado aí
eu falei para ele ali eu falei para a
gente fazer uma parada de fazer umas
coisas que fizesse barulho tipo assim
resolver uns problemas que tem da
sociedade mesmo Por exemplo quando a
gente tava indo para
o Piauí para o Maranhão Tinha muito
buraco na estrada de carro né aí no
Pirata das histórias eu falei para a
gente passava nos buraco Aí ele falasse
mais porque tá de carro aqui tá tudo bem
mas a pessoa de moto morrendo esse
buraco aqui aí a gente Pensou em fazer
assim um dispositivo que na trepidação
do pneu num buraco muito grande ele
solta uma tinta
fluorescente no asfalto tá ligado aí a
próxima pessoa que vem atrás quando o
bagulho bate em cima domina um Buracão
assim aí ela desvia tá ligado são coisas
simples não é nada muito sabe
tecnológico É só usar a tecnologia por
exemplo a trepidação tem que dar certo
senão o carro vai Onde tiver andando
batendo no mundo da Tartaruga não é
assim que é Macedo então tem todo um
estudo tem que partir de algum lugar e
partir de algum ponto entendeu E o
deficiente auditivo ele é muito excluído
da música tá ligado e a música só na
hora que nem ele tava falando para mim
ali dentro você chora com a música e
você não sabe a letra aquele negocinho
vai levando assim você tá triste tem um
momento aí você pô chora porque tá
sentindo aí o quê tudo bom Cadê
o que que a gente queria partir de algum
lugar para tentar incluir o deficiente
auditivo no mundo da música de uma forma
mais próxima assim tá ligado Tipo a
gente sabe por ele de alguns relatos né
de pessoas que já chegaram assim falando
Poxa eu queria que vocês usassem a
tecnologia para ver se tentava aproximar
a gente tinha uma menina que era muito
fã da Rihanna gostava muito da Rihanna e
disse que queria se sentir mais próxima
na música da Rihanna e a menina dançava
e tudo sabia dançar mas ela só sabia
dançar o que ela via ela imitava o
movimento da pessoa da frente mas ela
estava de fato sentindo a música que
tava rolando tá ligado e onda é uma
coisa antiga todo mundo sabe onda é onda
Você Grita ou Eco vem porque sua voz foi
bateu e voltou é um modinha que vai
ainda tem um tempo bate e volta é onda é
uma coisa antiga e já dá para a gente
aproximar já as ondas do deficiente
auditivo nessa questão do impulso da
música dele e aí a gente queria partir
de algum lugar
com a empresa lá mexeu e inventou
inventou é como se fosse uma caixa de
som só que ela já tá adaptada para ficar
amplificada aqui para o lado de dentro
na questão de pulsos assim mesmo sabe a
música que a gente escolheu para botar
São músicas que o grave da música tem
Tom sabe porque Por exemplo ele já disse
que pessoas que têm deficiência admitido
que vão no show elas conseguem que o
show elas ficam perto da caixa mas elas
escuta é o bumbo
Aí temos blitz são os glicose
é tão grave com tom não resolve o
problema mas dá tipo
tem aquela música Vampiro
aí
entendeu o bravo tá ligado ele ele falar
um pouco de ditongo e depois de um tempo
O cara consegue ouvir detalhes da música
por meio da sensibilidade e a ideia é
pegar as frequências né pegar as ondas e
deixar a apropriado para eles conseguir
escutar minha voz fina mas por aumentar
a frequência da minha voz fina e não do
som fina aquele lugar raptar esse essa
parada Tony Stark botar no peito vai dar
mas a ideia é e diminuindo né diminuindo
diminuindo diminuindo deixa a slim e eu
falei até para ele uma parada de tipo de
criar um próprio Hype dentro da própria
comunidade entendeu porque a gente pode
tirar uma do banheiro a gente comprou do
iPod da gente tá ligado Porque que o
cara não pode tirar onda porque ele
comprou um novo sei lá dá para dar uma
curtida no som muito
hein seguida Ei na frente e atrás ia ser
irado hein aí
eu tenho tanto vai parecer uma
ambulância
[Música]
mais saltos
se desenvolveu Porque tem uma uma
comunicação porque eu sou do cego né que
a gente faz quando faz libras Tati
alguém faz o som o sentido nas costas
Então essa sensibilidade nas costas
acaba sendo um pouco maior é assim o que
é que aconteceu aqui né numa pessoa no
indivíduo típico que escuta bem a gente
não tem aí persensibilidade porque não é
necessário no caso dela ela super
desenvolveu por isso que mesmo ela
colocando aqui a gente quase não ouve na
música Ela escuta perfeito é igual é
isso é bom pra estudo porque porque no
caso o aparelho não pode ser igual para
todo mundo ele tem que entrar na na na
aí tem que rolar por investimento ia
estudar na Tom Exatamente isso é um
estudo de músculo e ossos
aqui na frente acho que a batida mesmo
eu senti mais atrás mais alto e aqui na
frente é outras coisas da música é essa
parte que a gente quer resolver porque
por exemplo a gente queria que vocês
escutasse um coral mas aí como a gente
vai fazer essa pancadinha de voz tá
entendendo cara pois obrigado pela
experiência porque vocês foram os
primeiros a testar e esse aqui é o
primeiro então ele saiu assim vocês vão
primeiro iPhone vocês aí que é um trampo
hoje mesmo depois
você aprendeu mostra o que que você
aprendeu com ele
na comunidade ó pessoal
o sinal dele junto
foi isso Eu gostei muito Fiquei muito
feliz eu espero que vocês tenham gostado
também se você apoia e não esquece de ir
lá na Tron dá uma olhada sobre o que que
é a inserção da tecnologia na vida da
criança na grade curricular mesmo
piauiense da gente tô junto também e
vamos nessa clique em gostei é nós